third hour of the program on the radio
side NBC Sports Radio Hour - here on NBC
SN allo to our friends in Great Britain
on Sky Sports USA we are in Kansas City
Missouri in advance of Saturday's Colts
Chiefs game and the Colts have a lot of
great stories I don't want to get so
caught up in the Chiefs because we're
here in Kansas yeah I guess it holds
have been a great story this year they
started one in five they've turned it
around in large part because of their
first year head coach Frank Reich the
guy who wasn't even interviewed until
after Josh McDaniels left the Colts at
the altar following Super Bowl 52 Frank
Reich got his start in coaching late he
was an intern with our Tony Dunne Jets
right coach Dungy went to Indianapolis
this week to talk to Frank Reich here's
a little about what Frank Reich had to
say regarding his aggressive nature as a
head coach now watching that and the
Kansas City offense if I was in your
chair I'd be saying hey we've got to
control the ball and keep them off the
field I don't sense you feel that way I
don't that's your mindset it's like
that's not the mindset now I don't mind
if it plays out that way but our mindset
is to score every time we touch the ball
you know with the quarterback that we
have and then the skill guys that we
have and the guys up front that that's
the way we approach it so you're gonna
be aggressive we're gonna be aggressive
and let er rip I mean we know this team
scores points
I mean I'm confident in our defense is
going to play well we're gonna go out
there and try to score that's Frank
Reich with Tony Dungy you'll see the
full interview on the pregame show
tomorrow 3:00 p.m. Eastern on NBC a full
90 minutes and look I on one hand I hear
what Frank Craig has to say about being
aggressive and I got well maybe he's
just bluffing but then I think that's
the attitude that his players love it
dates back to the overtime game against
the Texans yep we criticize Frank Reich
for going for the win not settling for
the time when he was trying to instill
how to win a game and it did it work it
didn't work that day didn't work the
rest of the way
yeah exactly right and again I don't
expect the Colts to change their game
plan I mean I hear you you know it is
dangerous right when we talk about okay
you you want to get in the shootout with
Patrick mahomes and company but I think
that at the end of the day when they
evaluate Kansas City throughout the week
they go I mean we're just crazy if we
don't attack a defense that's giving up
273
yards a game in in pass yards it's the
second worse than all of football and
you haven't Andrew Luck so they're gonna
be I think still pipe with the same
formula we've really seen them play
throughout the stretch it's gonna be
probably about 6040 pass you can never
just go oh it's all pass and they'll
have some timely run cause and that's
the beauty of Frank Reich's offense I
really think it's it's so aggressive
down the field like an Andy Reid and a
Patrick mahomes and and trying to find
big pass plays there but he does have
some great creative run designs as well
that I got to give David to Gil mow
their other offensive line he's a guy
that was in New England that took over
for Dante scar never practicing that man
I think I still butchered it you did
this is a practice I do I do but he's he
is a very good offensive line coach and
the one thing I look at them every week
is go who they always have a few
wrinkles in their run game that I go
that's very creative way to block this
play or whatever it may be but I do I
expect this to be points points on the
board and the Colts the biggest thing I
think for them more than anything is
handling those opening emotions of this
football game we know that stadium is
gonna be on fire and they haven't seen
an offense like this all year you look
through the Colts history we talked
about it in the first hour there's
there's no high-powered offense this
Colts has had to defend all year when I
say that I mean great scheme with talent
and offensive line that's able to pass
protect like Kansas City and I think
we're gonna see a high-scoring fun game
like like we saw when it was Trent green
verse Peyton Manning back in the day
where it's just up and down the field
and you know who can make that big play
on defense to kind of swing the pendulum
yeah that was a playoff game very very
nice that was a playoff game here at
Arrowhead Stadium within the past 15
years the cults have won as many
postseason games at Arrowhead Stadium as
the Chiefs that's crazy
2 million - yeah so that one is gonna be
broken on Saturday and I look III think
the Chiefs overall or the better team
but the Colts are dangerous this were 9
and 1 down the stretch in the regular
season they went to Houston and won
convincingly over the Texans now it was
21 nothing and then it kind of tailed
off after that but I still think the
Colts right now everything Frank Reich
has done everything Chris Ballard the GM
has done it is magical it is special
remember when Chris Ballard told us back
at the league meetings right it's going
to take a couple of
to turn it around yeah it's turned
around yeah and and I can't wait to see
what his follow-up is after a draft last
year that brought Quentin Nelson round
one
Darius Leonard round trading Braden
Smith and round two teammates I know and
and they'll just get better and better
and better they get the cap space if
they want to go out make a big splash
that's right I don't think they should
pursue levy on bail that's just an
example a kind of name if they want to
yes they have the luxury to do it you're
gonna be wondering we want to be careful
not to screw up the chemistry of your
team I agree that's gonna be part of the
challenge when you can add these pieces
who do we add who do we resist and the
Colts I think the arrow is pointing up
and this is a team right now that really
any of the teams in the AFC can get to
the Super Bowl
yes any of them in the NFC I feel like
it's tilted toward the same shirt but
any of the remaining four AFC teams you
can make a very compelling case that
they're gonna win the next two games and
get to the superbug Reed I mean yeah I
would not be shocked if the 200 dogs won
the football games this weekend and we
were you know watching the the cults and
chargers play would be crazy I mean the
optics with that would be interesting to
see should just move the game to the
Coliseum if it comes to that but they
won't I was already talked as told weeks
ago if the Chargers host the AFC
Championship game it will be at their
stadium it won't move to the Coliseum
okay good I mean okay I wouldn't want
them to move the Coliseum play with
where you've been all year long but
you've got to give credit to the Colts
in in so many different areas I mean
first of all Chris Ballard like you were
saying just so impressive what he did
finding like some hidden gems within
there too I think that's the thing I
really look at and then Frank Reich I
mean a guy that I've crossed paths past
with paths with a few times in my life
he is such an impressive guy he's got a
great demeanor about him it's just like
it's this calmness but yet there's this
great confidence in him when you talk to
him and I think he's brought that to
their football team and this
fearlessness factor that they have shown
to where oh okay well hey we're one in
five we don't care we're just gonna
continue to keep you know chopping away
here and they have caught fire and
Andrew Luck is playing phenomenal
football and they are certainly
dangerous and as far as beating the
Kansas City Chiefs let's assume the
Patriots win YES on Sunday right and and
that's not an easy assumption no it's
not
thinking about the storylines that would
go into the AFC championship game coming
here to face the Chiefs right they'd
have to go on the road or having the
Colts come back four years after the
deflategate game right after the Josh
McDaniels jilting the Colts Frank Reich
taking over I I
there is no bad a FC Chico there is not
based on how this plays out but if the
Patriots make it you're gonna have great
story lines coming out of either
potential opponent and we'll know going
into Sunday who the Patriots would be
playing if they do hold serve at home
yeah that's right I would not be
disappointed in seeing really any
matchup that in either conference I mean
I do think we've gotten down to the best
eight teams in football it took the
Eagles a little while to finally get
there because we saw moments of all like
early on in the year but they found ways
to ruin games and mess things up to
where they really got behind the eight
ball and had to struggle to get in but
yeah I am Fassett I think I'm throwing
the challenge flag on you to you what
are you're saying right cuz you said all
year how good the Steelers are right
that the Steelers are one of the best
teams in fight I do that they should be
and it's their own fault they're not
playing this way yes you're right you're
right I think like the Steelers were one
of those teams where I looked at them
and said that they got in the playoffs
watch out and I wouldn't have been
shocked if we saw them in the AFC
Championship game so yeah no you're no
doubt about that but I think the ad
matchup I'm most intrigued to see just
as a true football fan would be New
England having to come here into Kansas
City and that rematch of the game we saw
earlier this year but now it's in Kansas
City's home turf and watching Patrick
mahomes the new verse the old and Brady
in my homes I think there's some
fascinating story lines there you know
there was a trend for years where the
one seed in the two seed was about a
50/50 proposition of losing in that
divisional round a variety of reasons
the bye week coasting down the stretch
absolutely a lot of momentum for the
team that won in the wild-card round in
recent years it's been one seeds into
seeds it advanced on it's looking like
for now I mean if if that holds we're
gonna have the two conference
championship games that we hoped for
right that we assumed we'd get Chiefs
Patriots rematch Saints Rams rematch
yeah but I have a feeling one of those
two is going to get disrupted some maybe
stuff yeah I mean it does seem that way
that would probably be too perfect for
the football gods to really feel good
about that but either way I don't think
we're gonna see any bad matchups next
week whether it's NFC or AFC and you
know hey with the Indianapolis Colts and
the Kansas City Chiefs matchup we've
talked a lot about a lot of things that
were excited to see can that pass rush
for the Chiefs get home against that
Colts offensive line and can the Chiefs
secondary slow down the Colts passing
game and their big pass plays because
they've been pretty underwhelming the
whole year long and then how's Patrick
mahomes Tyree killed Kelsie how are they
gonna play with the week off playoff
Andy Reed with a week off we know how
especially is there so many different
things and different angles you can talk
about in this game but I remember one of
your big talking points going in to the
Colts Texans game that the Colts
offensive line is good enough to
neutralize the pass rush of the Texas
yes and then the back end not good
enough to cover the t y Houghton's of
the work
you're exactly right and that's really
gonna be the big thing for the Kansas
City Chiefs Houston Ford Chris Jones you
know they were all almost in
double-digit sacks I mean Justin Houston
was the only one and I think he had nine
and a half sacks so this is one of the
best pass rushes in football this is
going to be very loud they're going to
get a little head start when they when
the ball is snapped because of the crowd
noise and and then the other side of the
ball - hey
the Colts defense it's sound it plays
well we know that but this is a
different animal they haven't seen
anything like this all year long and I
would expect hey we always talk about
Andy Reid off by weeks right Mike and
how awesome he is throughout his career
whether it was Philadelphia or Kansas
City with winning those games off a bye
week I think we're gonna see some things
brought out in the in the pass game
schematically and we're gonna go oh wow
that was a cool little wrinkle he added
in for the game before we take a break a
factor that we need to consider it's the
weather yes two to five inches of snow
now the snow is supposed to end before
kickoff yeah but I'm looking at wind
speeds around 10 or 11 miles per hour
yeah windchill in the mid 20s yeah what
will you will you go hat and gloves so
do you are you gonna I heard like at the
Notre Dame games you'd have your hat in
your gloves on and then when it's time
to do your spot you take them off and
act like you're tough guy in the coal
and then you put them all back well I
don't try to act like a tough guy
guy I mean I don't know yeah I did I
tried to do that you know I I don't know
I I probably won't wear a hat for the TV
segments I don't always love that but I
will have some gloves on that cold who
does it benefit if it's wet if the field
and the field they'll have the field
covered but the wind and the cold is
gonna be a factor is that a Chiefs
benefit or try to call coaches are done
you know I know I look at that I look at
the Colts though and go well at least
they have a power running game they
could rely on if it got nasty and they
can do that that's where I maybe look at
the avenge now Kansas City has a very
good offensive line we just know they
don't love to run the football you know
you'd think about the quarterbacks too
and you hear about the win for all those
that are out there win stinks for a
quarterback I'd almost rather play and a
little like like rain or or something
like that because wind you have to
adjust how you throw the ball at times
where you go oh wait we're in the wind
or there's a sideway win I got to place
this ball here and play the wind to take
it almost to a degree but I think these
are two quarterbacks that will not be
affected by the wind Mike because they
are spiral throwers that have great arms
and I think they'll be able to throw
through the wind for the most part and
not be affected by that in the past game
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports